E
>> RGUEDS BEFORE RL ANSWERS.
E AND-19W NT IDENTIFIED A
CORONAVIRUS.
DRNUMBERS. E SUS
>>ter: MORE 0 MUTA SCIENTIST, IE
SPIKE PROTEIONIT'SSIGN.
WN MBLING TDETERMINE IF IT
CRUCIALLY WEAKENS VACCIN
ANSWES..
>> WE THINK IT MAY BE MO
AND MAY
WE DON'T KNOW THAT F
THAT'S WHA LIK COMMISSION TODAHO
TE THEMERGENRAN
TRAVEL FROUNIE S
AFRICA.
>> Reporter: COUNTRIES ALL IDNG
NOW THOUSANDS AR NT.
SITN THE  AMSTERDAM, HUNDREDS O
TA A LANDITHA STSILANDS BANSVEL.
THE L TRSOCIATION SAYING RESTRI
ART SOLUTION.ADLOS HED ANGEINOU
OFFICIALS CALL THE BANS
DRAC KRKTRESSING WAS NOTENTHAT
THERE WAS NO THETHAT TRE GOING
HE UCONTROL THE OUTBREAK.
TT THERE
IS THIVAT IN THE U.S.
NF MOMENT.
JUST MOMENTS AGO, NEN THAT THE
TO VER THIS T WILL SPREAD THROUN
ISE TRANSMISSIBLE,
AFRICAN Y TRAVELS
NO AND
SEVERAISTS EXPEDO
ME TODT THE COMIICKLY WITH THES.
JIM?>>EN YOU EW FROM HERE, AT T.
ARE CO
JOINING ME IS DRR
TEXACHILDREN'S HOSPITAL, AND
MEDICINE AYLOR.
R.D A FEELING WE WS SC SOO
VARIANT WAS GOODS T
WE GOD A NEW ALERTRO
SA A VERHIGHSK -- HIGH TO VERY E
N TO BEVERY LONG BEFO O
.EL FHTS.
ONE, THIS IS THE CONSEQUENCEF
G NA THE AFRIC
CONTINENT.
ONLYNEALS VACCINEDNEDITIONAL VAE
S OF CONCERN
POPULATIONS.INATED
THE FACT THEREAS A
-FFFT BEYO
MR AVE VCOULD VE THEICAN
T VACCINATED BNOW HA
WE DONTHAT.
SO PART OF D WOUND, BUT
ORTANT E THERE'S CONCERN, BUT
THY IS FAL.
HERE WHYJIM.FIRST, TT DOES NOTO
DIEGTHG WE HFORE.
THEDIT'S NIKE MORTIT
EVEN FURTHE THI
THE SECO P,
THERE'S ATIONS
SPE PROTEIN, INCLUDING THE
RECE B IN
THE PAST THOSE
CAPEARVE
TRANSLATED INTO MAJOR GLOBAL
PATHS GENS
BEFORE, BUWITH BT,AR, THOSE NEVE
REK  NOTHING INTRINSICTHE SPE N
THSE OUT OF THEUU UK, AN
SUTUCAT TO ,SEF AMINO ACID
MRE HIGHLY
TRANSMISSIE.SOHE  WEEND AND NEX-
IT'S POSSIBLE, BUT WE STILL HAV.
THE DELTA VARIANT HAS BEEN
SO I TTHINGS  KEPT IN
METHAT.
A RELEASED
ST SHORT T OF
THREESA,  SIGNINTVACCINERNA REL
HOW CONCERNED ARE YOABOU
WEEKEND, R RK OUR
OTN AT TEXASS
WE'RINIBODE MODERNA PFIZER, AND
SA.T SOME I
ABILITY TO CEUTRALIZE TH
VARIANT IN
IT'S T SAM B SINDICATION.
I THIN GOING TBE
IMPORTANT AS BUT IS IT
THIS RIGHT N
FASTESS IL POPULATWE HAVE % THAE
WEEN
THAT HAVONLY GO DOSES WA
IMMUNIANE  AND HAVMPLETE IIT BE
EY VCI
OESN'THANGE.
THE TRAVELICTIONS, WSEENIG IMP I
RICTIONS FROM CHINA, WHEN
ME THIR TO NEW YORK CITY FROM S
>> I SPOKEY BRIE